ce qui est en question ce soir c'est
l'unité de la république
c'est elle qui a été piétinée vendredi à
conflans comme elle l'a été à charlie
hebdo et au bataclan en 2015 comme elle
l'est chaque jour par ce qui oblige
sonia mabrouk milla zineb el-rhazoui
salman rushdie et tant d'autres à vivre
sous protection policière
comme elle est piétinée par ce qui
empêche au quotidien des milliers de
filles et de femmes musulmanes de se
vêtir comme elles veulent étudier à
l'école publique est parfois tout
simplement de sortir de chez elle
cet assaut l'islamisme le mène dans le
monde entier contre les musulmans qui
n'appliquent pas la charia contre les
chrétiens les juifs les athées mais en
europe c'est la france qui est la
première visée en raison notamment d'un
des piliers de notre république que les
fondamentalistes haïssent la laïcité
puisque les l'islamisme nous déclare la
guerre il faut d'abord parler de nos
succès le califat d'où partaient chaque
jour des terroristes à destination de
l'europe pour y commettre des attentats
majeurs a disparu grâce à une coalition
où la france joue un rôle essentiel
grâce à cela les attentats d'aujourd'hui
aussi horrible soit ils sont commis par
des loups solitaires demi fou livrés à
eux-mêmes à l'armé blanche et non au
fusil d'assaut en bande organisée la
france est aussi au sahel quasi seul
hélas pour empêcher les djihadistes
d'établir de nouvelles bases arrières
pour d'autres un terrain de masse mais
paradoxalement cette bataille contre
l'islamisme c'est chez nous que nous
risquons de la perdre les derniers
chiffres font froid dans le dos 74% des
musulmans de moins de 25 ans pensent que
leurs convictions religieuses past avant
les lois de la république contre 25 %
des plus de 35 ans ce constat effarant
n'est pas le résultat de la seule
propagande salafistes il est aussi le
résultat de nos propre lâcheté qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
le rapport obin de 2004 soigneusement
mis sous le tapis les accommodements de
tant de chefs de service avec les
atteintes à la laïcité afin d'éviter des
ennuis
notre incapacité à maîtriser les flux
migratoires et les filières mafieuses
ce détournement des procédures d'asile
l'impossibilité de mettre en oeuvre les
mesures d'expulsion pour 85% des
personnes concernées les quatre mille
étrangers fichier fs perte est encore
sur le territoire les ratés de la chaîne
police justice dont les maillons
judiciaire est aujourd'hui le plus
faibles minées par le manque de moyens
et par l'ultra gauche judiciaire en déni
de réalité
il ne manquait plus que l'idée abandonné
in extremis de fer s'agenouiller des
policiers place beauvau pour ce protest
pour se prosterner devant les
indigéniste et les des coloniaux c'est
lâche t il est d'autant plus difficile
de supposer qu'elles sont puissamment
aidé par le choeur des pleureuses du
camp du bien des victimes au crac et des
indignés professionnels prêts à bondir
sur toutes mesures de fermeté en criant
à la discrimination et à la
stigmatisation
il est difficile aussi de s'opposer à ce
qui est en train de devenir le cancer de
nos sociétés démocratiques
ce n'est plus seulement dans les
mosquées salafistes ou dans les prisons
que se recrutent les djihadistes c'est
sur le web devenu l'écosystème des fake
news du complotisme de la haine est
désormais des influenceurs islamistes
l'assassinât samuel patty a été préparé
et peut être programmé par une salve
d'appel au meurtre sur les pages
salafistes la mise au pas des réseaux
anti sociaux est une urgence et il ne
faut pas compter sur les milliardaires
opérateurs de ces plateformes pour le
faire spontanément eux qui voudraient
nous faire croire parce que ça fait plus
de clics
donc plus de fric que les délits que
sont les appels à la haine à la colère
au meurtre et à tout ce qui peut
gangréné nos sociétés démocratiques font
parti de la liberté d'expression il fut
un temps où la france se poser moins de
questions
l accompagner elle accueillait les
vagues de migrants et elle les assimiler
c'était le mot qu'on employait à
l'époque et il ne choquer personne ni
les français ni les immigrés notre pays
était alors sur de son modèle
républicain de sa conception de la
laïcité
notre façon de vivre ensemble et de sa
place dans le monde
le plus grand défi aujourd'hui n'est-il
pas de réussir l'intégration dans un
pays qui voit ses valeurs s'estomper
comme s'efface peu à peu à la surface de
la mer un visage de sable le plus grand
défi n'est-il pas de convaincre que ces
valeurs ne sont pas seulement celles du
passé mais aussi celle de l'avenir c'est
ce à quoi nous appelle les auteurs de
cette proposition de loi
bien sûr cet exercice a ses limites
parce que cette proposition si elle est
adoptée un jour le sera au terme
forcément lointain d'une révision
constitutionnelle alors que depuis
vendredi les français attendent des
actes plus que des lois mais le but de
ces auteurs n'est sans doute pas
seulement là il est de nous proposer un
sursaut de réveiller face au danger un
pays qui s'assoupit dans ce domaine
comme dans d'autres îles et de rappeler
comme le faisait samuel pâti à ses
élèves avec beaucoup de courage et de
lucidité que si nous devions abandonner
les valeurs qui ont fondé notre
république la france ne mériterait plus
de s'appeler la france c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous voterons cette promo